it's been a few years since Disney's
frozen burst onto the screen so we
wouldn't blame you if you've let go of
some of the finer details of the plot
fortunately we've gathered together
everything you need to know before
heading to the theater for the sequel
originally conceived as a loose
retelling of the Hans Christian Andersen
tale The Snow Queen the initial vision
for frozen looked a lot different than
the movie Disney wound up releasing in
the original script Elsa was an
indisputable villain she and Anna
weren't sisters or even royalty and the
story culminated in a climactic battle
featuring an army of snow monsters and a
devastating avalanche
however director Chris buck and writer
and eventual co-director Jennifer Lee
realized something was missing and
decided to make its two central
characters sisters instead of strangers
[Music]
journeyman snowman the final piece of
the frozen puzzle fell into place when
songwriters Kristen anderson-lopez and
Robert Lopez wrote their first song that
would make it into the finished film let
it go after hearing the song Lee and
Buck realized they couldn't keep Elsa a
villain and rewrote the script in order
to make her more of a conflicted co-lead
the final version of the film featured a
pair of sisters who loved each other
dearly but were driven apart by Elsa's
inability to control her powers this
change also required the filmmakers to
reimagine the character of Olaf from a
villainous henchmen into a lovable goofy
sidekick come on could you even imagine
this guy getting up to no good as
evidenced by the original film's
twisting path to the screen frozen was a
collaborative effort between the writers
directors and songwriters and wouldn't
have come to exist in its current form
without any one of those specific
people's input fortunately the whole
team is returning for the sequel albeit
in slightly altered roles Chris buck is
back in the co-directors chair as is
Jennifer Lee who was also named head of
Walt Disney Animation Studios in 2018 on
the music front songwriters Kristen
anderson-lopez and Robert Lopez are
returning with 11 original new songs for
the soundtrack and Christophe Beck is
coming back to
pose the score the only significant
difference in the creative team between
frozen and frozen - is the screenwriters
while the original movie script was
penned by co-director Jennifer Lee
she'll share rating duties on the second
film with Alison Schroeder who wrote the
screenplay for 2018 s heartwarming
Christopher Robin Schroder was also
nominated for an Oscar for her
screenplay for 2017 s hidden figures
making her a strong addition to the
frozen teen frozen tells the tale of the
two daughters of the king and queen of
arendelle Elsa the elder sister and Anna
the younger one although the two were
closest children they drifted apart
after their parents taught Elsa that the
best way to deal with her magical icy
powers was to conceal them from the
world and to repress her emotions as a
result Elsa has isolated herself and
only poles further away when the king
and queen are lost at sea however as the
oldest daughter its
Elsa's duty to take up the crown but on
the day of her coronation she loses
control of her powers and flees the
kingdom onit pursues her into the
mountains aided by the ice Harvester
Kristoff and his trusty reindeer Sven
hoping to convince Elsa to end the
sudden winter she's created in Arundale
convinced she can't control her powers
Elsa accidentally freezes on his heart a
spell that will slowly kill her dying
and heartbroken honor returns to
Erindale where the sinister Hans is in
the midst of maneuvering to take control
of the kingdom but before he can kill
Elsa and seize the crown honest stops
him and her act of true love and saving
her sister thaws her heart
realizing love is the key to controlling
her powers Elsa ends the magical winter
reconciles with Anna and takes up her
crown as queen of arendelle
although six years will have passed for
us between frozen and frozen
- according to Disney's head of
animation Becky Brizzy the story of
frozen - will begin three years after
the end of the first film
Brizzy told The Hollywood Reporter it's
an evolution and an expansion of the
story of frozen and many of the
questions raised in the first movie
become the mystery
our gang are trying to solve in this
film she added that the main question of
frozen to will be why was Elsa born with
her powers your power will only grow
there is beauty in it
but also great danger but for anyone
worried that frozen to s mystery
centered storyline will be a departure
from the first film's focus on the
relationship between two sisters
you can put your fears to rest Disney's
head of effects Marlon West a short thr
that the sequel is ultimately quote
about two sisters trying to stay
together while the world tries to tear
them apart that sounds like exactly what
we'd hoped for after the emotional
family driven tale of the first film
based on the trailers Disney has
released four frozen two we can start to
piece together some of the plot in the
beginning all appears to be well in
Arundale with Queen also ruling
peacefully over her subjects from her
gently iced frosted castle but some sort
of malevolent unseen force manifesting
as pink flames drives the errand aliens
out of their homes determined to get to
the bottom of what's happened to them
and fix it
anna and elsa set off on a quest
accompanied by Kristoff Sven and Olaf
while the first film focused mostly on
Anna Elsa looks to be the main
protagonist of frozen - as she attempts
to track down the source of a mysterious
voice she hears calling to her she hopes
to discover the source of her powers and
through that knowledge somehow save her
kingdom
the trailers also indicate that an
enchanted forest in the far north will
prove to be significant to the two
sisters and possibly provides some
further clues about the backstory of
their parents in discussing the story
for frozen two directors Chris buck and
Jennifer Lee together with songwriters
Kristen anderson-lopez and Robert Lopez
realized they still had a few big
lingering questions after the events of
the first film
so they set about creating a story that
would answer them if the biggest
question is indeed why does Elsa have
her powers then that leads to a logical
follow-up
why doesn't Anna have powers in digging
into answers about the two sisters it
becomes obvious that we really need to
know more about their parents which
calls into question the circumstances
surrounding their deaths according to
Lee although the first film implied that
the king and queen were headed away on
roots
business when their ship sank things may
not all be as they appear during the
2019 d23 Expo Li T's the question where
were their parents really going when
that ship went down we've been promised
that the answers to all these questions
and more will be revealed in frozen -
although audiences were introduced
briefly to King Agner and Queen I Doudna
at the beginning of frozen they died
very early on in the film's narrative
and we learned almost nothing about them
at least nothing beyond their
instructions to Elsa concede don't fear
it ignore and die Doudna weren't given
names in the first film and had hardly
any lines for they're all too short
presents the Queen was voiced by
co-director Jennifer Lee with veteran
voice actor Maurice LaMarche
as the king for their expanded roles in
frozen 2 however the royal couple will
be voiced by Alfred Molina and Evan
Rachel Wood judging by her two songs on
the movie soundtrack I do know we'll
have a particularly hefty role and
according to Disney's press release the
Queen will begin to wonder if the
answers she seeks can be found in her
own past the press release has less to
say about Agner saying only that he'll
do anything to protect his daughters
from harm but the casting of the Golden
Globe and Emmy nominated Molina makes it
seem as though the king will have a
significant part to play as well
joining the impressive cast for frozen -
which includes nearly every major player
and a few returning minor characters
from the first movie is this is us
actors sterling K Brown who will be
voicing lieutenant Destin Mattias in
arendale soldier who's been trapped in
the enchanted forest for more than 30
years
lieutenant Mattias has according to
Disney's press release never forgotten
his sworn duty to Erindale but the
arrival of Queen Elsa and discovery that
she has magical powers is just the first
of many challenges to his long-held
beliefs
lieutenant Mattias originally travelled
to the forest to fight against the
nomadic north all drew people presumably
the enemies of Arundale however when we
see him in the trailer he and his men
appear to be standing alongside the
north ultra raising the question of
whether the animosity between the two
groups was some sort of MIS
standing or whether the trailer is
simply working to mislead us a
significant theme running through the
first frozen was about first impressions
being unreliable as evidenced with both
Elsa and Hans and we wouldn't be
surprised if it carries through to the
sequel in an even more prominent way
frozen may have had a compelling plot
but the sequel will be broadening the
scope of the series storytelling quite a
bit not only will Anna and Elsa be
venturing far outside the borders of
arendelle but they'll also be meeting
new people who at least at first glance
appear very different from them joining
the cast of frozen 2 are several members
of the north all drew people including
their leader Jelena the bold and brave
honey Maren and the eager fun-loving
Rider
according to Disney's press release
Alana is fiercely protective of her
family and community but is known to
soften when people show an understanding
of nature and their environment
meanwhile frozen tooths new pair of
siblings honey Maren and Ryder seem to
have views that could put them at odds
with honey Maren being a true free
spirit who wants nothing more than to
bring peace to the enchanted forest
while Ryder longs to embrace the world
and venture beyond the magical mist
it'll be interesting to see how this
brother and sister Pere plays against
Erin Dale's royal sisters and whether
they will all be able to work together
or wind up butting heads as only
siblings can while the original film
introduced us to such nonhuman favorites
as Olaf the snowman's then the reindeer
and a colony of trolls frozen to looks
to significantly expand its roster of
mystical magical and just plain adorable
creatures knock the water spirit can be
seen in the trailer as the watery horse
that Elsa encounters in the ocean
Disney's press release states that NOK
is a fierce warrior and guards the
secrets of the forest fiercely and that
to get past it a person must prove they
are worthy and earn its respect an
almost impossible task however based on
the brief shot of Elsa riding the water
stallion in the trailer it appears as
though she manages to impress knocks on
how frozen - will also introduce us to
Gale a playful wind spirit who can
seemingly be seen in the trailer tossing
leaves and children up into the air in
addition there are the massive stone
earth Giants who we see in the trailer
towering over the treetops of the
enchanted forest will also meet Bruni a
salamander who lives in the enchanted
forest who is fascinated by Elsa's
powerful ice magic after Elsa spent so
much of the first movie in isolation
it'll be nice to see her make a tiny new
friend in this one and if Josh GAD
tweets and Bruni's adorable Japanese
character poster are any indication when
we finally meet Bruni on screen we fully
expect to fall in love with the little
guy ourselves check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite disney
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]